[Musik]
hallo schönen guten Abend willkommen zu
ZDF heute live
afd-bundesparteitag in Magdeburg in
Zeiten eines
umfragedauer Hochs aktuell liegt die
Partei bei 18 bis 22 Prozent in Umfragen
wie stellt sich die AFD auf führt an ihr
kein Weg mehr vorbei so wie es die
Parteichefin sagt und welche Antworten
haben die anderen Parteien darüber
wollen wir heute reden und über vieles
anderes mehr deshalb schickt uns eure
Fragen und eure Kommentare die schreibt
am besten in die Chats oder ihr schickt
uns eine E-Mail wir sprechen dann gleich
mit dem Politikwissenschaftler Benjamin
Höhne und jetzt erstmal mit Hauptstadt
von nentin Nicole Dietmann live aus
Magdeburg hallo Nicole
hi hallo
Nicole du hast schon einige afd-partei
Tage erlebt da ging es dann auch immer
mal wieder ordentlich zur Sache wie
erlebst du die Partei heute
das ist ja heute ein Treffen einer
Partei die sich in einem ich würde sagen
Zustand der sehr zufriedenen
Selbstvergewisserung befindet man ist
natürlich total zufrieden mit diesem
Höhenflug den du eben schon angesprochen
hast außerdem hat man gerade zum ersten
Mal eine Landratswahl gewonnen und kurze
Zeit später die Wahl eines
hauptamtlichen Bürgermeisters man ist
hier zusammengekommen um sich ein
bisschen zu feiern um einander noch mal
zu versichern wie stark man ist und dass
diese Stärke auch anhalten wird und das
fand ich heute sehr interessant einer
der beiden Bundesvorsitzenden Tino
propala hat hier eine Rede gehalten und
in dieser Rede
unfreiwillig würde ich sagen einen
wunden Punkt offen gelegt er hat nämlich
sehr darauf gedrungen dass die aktuelle
Stärke der AFD in den Umfragen auch aus
der eigenen Programmatik also aus dem
eigenen Handeln aus der eigenen Politik
resultiert denn da gibt es Zweifel es
gibt auch die Theorie dass diese Stärke
vor allem der schwäch e der anderen
Parteien zuvor dass der Ampelkoalition
in Berlin zu verdanken ist und einer aus
der AFD und nicht irgendjemand sondern
der Ehrenpräsident alexander gauland hat
diese These neulich auch in einem
Interview vertreten also da wird man
sich hier heute aktiv dagegen und sagt
nein wir sind eine programmatische
Partei wir sind nicht nur die Partei der
protestfehler und deshalb wird dieser
Höhenflug auch weitergehen
da werden wir gleich noch vertiefen
drüber reden jetzt lass uns mal erstmal
gemeinsam schauen worum es eigentlich
geht also heute ist ja regulärer
Parteitag und dann soll so ist es
zumindest geplant an diesem und am
nächsten Wochenende eine
europawahlversammlung stattfinden Jonas
Kapp fast und sie wichtigsten Punkte
zusammen
die AFD fordert den ukrainekrieg mit
diplomatischen Mitteln zu beenden und
wirbt für die sofortige Aufhebung aller
Sanktionen gegen Russland
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine sollen
gestoppt werden außerdem soll
Deutschland keine weiteren Flüchtlinge
aus der Ukraine aufnehmen ob Migranten
überhaupt in die EU kommen dürfen und
Asylverfahren durchgeführt werden das
soll nach Ansicht der AFD jeder
Nationalstaat selbst entscheiden können
die EU-Außengrenzen sollen
gemeinschaftlich abgeriegelt werden mit
Hilfe der grenzschutzbehörde frontext
weigern sich nicht EU-Staaten Menschen
zurückzunehmen will die AFD Ihnen unter
anderem die Entwicklungshilfe streichen
die Partei will zudem alle national en
und europäischen klimaschutzgesetze
abschaffen Subventionen für Solar und
Windenergie sollen wegfallen stattdessen
soll die Kohle Verstromung erhalten
bleiben und Atomkraftwerke langfristig
wieder ans Netz gehen
bleiben wir beim Thema Europa da stand
im Text dass die AFD eine geordnete
Auflösung der EU will aber dann hat die
Parteispitze gesagt das werden
redaktioneller Fehler gewesen was was
war das für eine Nummer
ja das ist ein sehr interessanter und
selbst für afd-verhältnisse
außerordentlicher Vorgang dass das
gerade gesagt es gibt einen Leitantrag
den gibt es auch noch der liegt auch
noch vor der soll hier beraten werden
indem die Auflösung der EU gefordert
wird das ist ja nicht nicht sondern das
ist schon eine Hausnummer und
da ist jetzt die Frage wer hat mit wem
nicht gesprochen wurde das an ähm an der
Bundesspitze an der Parteispitze vorbei
versucht zu schmuggeln man weiß es nicht
genau angeblich das ist ja auch gerade
gesagt ein redaktioneller Fehler
die Frage ist bzw dieser Vorgang zeigt
also die Bundesspitze der Bundesvorstand
hat sich klar dazu geäußert man wolle
das nicht es sei eben ein Fehler dem
müsste man beheben und einen Antrag
gestellt diesen Leitantrag wiederum an
dieser Stelle zu ändern was dieser
Vorgang zeigt ist erstens professionell
arbeiten geht ein bisschen anders und
zweitens da sind anscheinend ganz
grundlegende Fragen in der AFD nämlich
eben die nicht ganz navidare Frage nach
einer Auflösung der EU noch nicht
geklärt deswegen ist die Frage ob die
Geschlossenheit die man in den
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten in der
AFD gesehen hat nach außen und auf die
man auch einen Teil des derzeitigen
Erfolg ist hier in der Partei
zurückführt ob die sich weiter so
aufrecht erhalten lässt oder ob sie z.B
an dieser Frage hier in den nächsten
Tagen noch ein großer Streit entzünden
wird und dazu schreibt Gilbert grau auf
Facebook die EU auflösen wollen obgleich
das nicht allein durch Deutschland geht
da merkt man doch dass diese Partei
jeglichen Kontakt zur Realität verloren
hat
ist das so ein bisschen der Punkt der da
immer wieder durchkommt dass ähm ja
timala heute betont hat sie sind eine
konstruktive Partei eine macher-partei
das aber dieses wir sind dagegen und wir
wollen das nicht immer mal wieder
Durchfall
noch mal einmal zum User das stimmt
natürlich das ist relativ unrealistisch
dass ein einzelner Staat die EU auflösen
kann aber fordern kann man ja erstmal
das ist jetzt kein
Alleinstellungsmerkmal der AFD erstmal
Forderungen zu stellen und anschließend
zu schauen wie realistisch ist das da
muss man fair sein wenngleich diese
Förderung natürlich auch wirklich noch
mal eine eigene Hausnummer ist
du hast mich gerade
gefragt fragst du mich bitte noch mal
ich habe deine Frage vergessen na klar
ich frag Dich gerne noch mal ob dieses
gegen die EU sein auflösen wollen nicht
eher dafür spricht dass die AFD in
dieser
oppositionsecke in dieser wir sind
dagegen Ecke doch weiter verharrt und
auch bleiben wird
genau das ist Alleinstellungsmerkmal der
AFD dass sie aus Prinzip immer dagegen
ist das kann man so grob zusammenfassen
ich habe diesen Leitantrag für den jetzt
anstehenden Teil dieses dieser dieses
Treffens hier dieses entkommen des
Wochenende diesen europa-teil
durchgelesen ist sind ein paar mehr
Seiten als 100 Seiten und habe mir mal
den Spaß erlaubt durchzuzählen wie oft
die Formulierung lehnen wir ab vorkommt
wenn ich das auch richtig weiß waren es
über 20 Mal und das ist ja nur eine
Formulierung der Leitantrag strotzt von
Dingen die man nicht will von Dingen die
wieder abzuschaffen sind andere sagen
die strotzen von einer Zeit in die man
zurück will die aktuelle Zeit soll
zurückgedreht werden aber ich habe das
ja eben schon gesagt das scheint ein
wunder Punkt hier zu sein das hört man
ganz offensichtlich nicht gerne weil das
heute ein paar mal versucht wurde hier
an das darzustellen
und bei aller Harmonie die gerade
beschworen wird wo siehst du die größten
Streitpunkte wo könnte es noch klappen
wie gerade eben schon gesagt die Frage
was will man mit der EU eigentlich
machen das ist einer da könnte es Ärger
geben und es querscht im Hintergrund das
hört man aus mehreren Ecken in Sachen
Kanzlerkandidat oder Kanzlerkandidatin
Alice Weidel hat vor einigen Wochen den
Anspruch erhoben in einem Interview ihre
Partei sei gerade so erfolgreich da sei
es natürlich alles andere als
unrealistisch einen Kanzlerkandidaten
oder eben eine ganze Kandidatin zu
ernennen
wie man hört war das nicht abgesprochen
das bestreiten sie und hinopalla aber
trotzdem halten sich die Gerüchte das
sei bitte nicht abgesprochen gewesen ähm
das wird von vielen so interpretiert
dass alles Weidel mit diesem Interview
mit dieser Forderung ein Block
eingeschlagen hat weil sie damit quasi
die Nase ein kleines Stückchen vorne hat
und sich damit als mögliche
Kanzlerkandidatin ins Gespräch bringt
das ist jetzt erstmal kein großes Thema
aber das könnte das scheint unter der
Oberfläche noch ein bisschen zu brodeln
das könnte noch mal aufploppen und das
ist ja ein Thema das Alice Weidel
durchaus immer mal wieder zur Sprache
bringt gerade heute morgen im ZDF MoMA
da hat sie das Thema angesprochen wir
hören uns im Irrtum kurz mal
[Musik]
ich sage ganz klar die AFD unsere Partei
die in den Umfragen sich stabilisiert
hat vor der Kanzlerpartei SPD
zweitstärkste Kraft bundesweit ist nur
noch vier Prozent hinter der CDU muss
eine Führungsanspruch stellen und den
stellen sie nur mit Aufstellung eines
Kanzlerkandidaten
wird sie versuchen in Magdeburg sich
diesbezüglich weiter in Stellung zu
bringen
na das tut sie natürlich mit jedem
Interview dass sie gibt mit jedem O-Ton
den sie uns gibt mit jeder Äußerung die
sie hier tätigt damit hier sehr präsent
zu sein man muss aber eine Sache zu
dieser Kanzlerkandidatur sagen das ist
eine PR-Nummer das ist auch politisches
Handwerk das ist Aufgabe von
Politikerinnen und Politikern das zu tun
aber natürlich weiß alles Weidel genauso
wie der Rest ihrer Partei dass die AFD
sicherlich in nah und wahrscheinlich
auch mittelfristiger Zukunft nicht ins
Kanzleramt einziehen wird das hat
mehrere Gründe warum sie das getan hat
der eine ist in dem Moment in dem sie
die Förderung erhoben hat gab es
Berichterstattung über die AFD und
Parteien Leben von Berichterstattung und
das andere ist vielleicht auch nicht
ganz unwesentlich wer einen
Kanzlerkandidaten stellt oder eine
Kanzlerkandidatin nimmt an den
kanzlerduellen im Vorfeld einer
Bundestagswahl Teil das darf man nicht
außer Acht lassen muss immer wieder
fragen warum wir diese Forderung
überhaupt erhoben
und Alexander gauland du hast es ja
vorhin angesprochen ist ihr
diesbezüglich kann man sagen eigentlich
auch schon in den Rücken gefallen weil
er ja gesagt hat also der Erfolg der AFD
ist begründet auf den Fehlern der
anderen Parteien und daher hält er eine
Kanzlerkandidatur für mich realistisch
genau das hat er ziemlich frank und frei
anscheinend einer Kollegin von der Zeit
gesagt auch das soll hinter den Kulissen
für großen Ärger gesorgt haben was
natürlich auch folgerichtig ist also
niemand freut sich in einer Partei
darüber wenn jemand wie der
Ehrenpräsident der alexander gauland ist
sich dermaßen gegen die eigene Partei
stellt aber er hat es gemacht und hat es
auch nicht zurückgenommen
schreibt meine doofe Frage gewesen
Fragen also ist nicht jeder auf dich
einer Partei immer auf ein Zeichen für
die Schwäche der anderen Parteien selbst
wenn es das Programm ausmacht ist es
doch der starke Programm
das ist eine gute Frage die wird sich in
aller Reinheit in aller Klarheit
natürlich nie beantworten lassen die
Frage ist ja eher wie stark profitiert
die AFD von der Schwäche der anderen
beziehungsweise um die mal umzudrehen
wie schnell
würden werden die diese Rekordwerte der
AFD wieder runtergehen wenn die anderen
Parteien wenn die Ampelkoalition die ja
in den vergangenen Monaten durch immense
Zerstrittenheit aufgefallen ist wieder
liefern wie man so schön sagt das ist ja
der Umkehrschluss der daraus folgt und
das ist natürlich auch eine Sorge die
hier mitschwingt auch wenn die keiner
formulieren möchte die Sachen Punkt den
wir gleich noch mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler Benjamin Höhne
besprechen wollen zum Schluss letzte
Frage an dich am CDU-Chef märz mit
seinen Aussagen über eine Zusammenarbeit
mit der AFD auf kommunaler Ebene wie
weit ist das Thema in Magdeburg
das ist ein riesiges Thema zum einen hat
März der AFD das beschert was ich eben
schon genannt habe Bericht Erstattung
das schlaglich diese Woche wurde nicht
nur gerichtet auf März nach seiner
Äußerung im ZDF sommerinterview sondern
auch noch mal auf die AFD und die
beansprucht hier natürlich für sich in
allen Reden die ich hier heute gehört
habe zu sagen seht ihr es ist Realität
auch die CDU sieht es mittlerweile ein
also der Name Friedrich Merz wenn der
hier heute in der Halle viel von Rednern
das waren Garant dafür großen Applaus zu
ernten
liebe Nicole vielen Dank für deine
Berichterstattung von diesem Parteitag
der AFD mach's gut bis bald tschüss
bis bald danke auch tschüss
also eine zumindest nach außen hin
geschlossene AFD beflügelt durch ihr
Umfrage hoch damit gehen wir jetzt zum
Politikwissenschaftler Benjamin Höhne
den wird dann jetzt auch hoffentlich
gleich sehen
da ist er guten Abend Herr Hühne
wird das halten diese aktuelle Harmonie
innerhalb der AFD
das ist schon bemerkenswert für die AFD
weil sie ja notorisch zerstritten ist
wir sehr viel Flügelkämpfe beobachten
konnten seit Anbeginn an seit 2013
recht stark geschlossen ich glaube das
ist auch so gewollt man schaut sich an
welche Fehler die anderen Parteien
machen wie sich cdu/csu positioniert
sich dabei ein Stück weit zurück und
versucht möglichst lange auch der
demoskopischen auf dem demoskopischen
hoch auf dieser demoskopische Welle zu
reiten
auf der anderen Seite wissen wir aus der
Vergangenheit auch die AFD ist eine
relativ streitbare Partei wir haben es
eben auch vorhin gehört Alexander
gauland sieht den aktuellen Erfolg der
AFD vor allem mehr in den Fehlern der
anderen Partei sehen Sie das auch so
dass die AFD mit der Krise mit den
Krisen wächst und mit den besseren
Zeiten dann auch wieder schrumpft
man kann glaube ich schon sagen dass
rechts populistische Parteien Krisen
gewinnerparteien sind sie sind auch im
Grunde spezialisiert darauf Krisen für
sich zu nutzen zu instrumentalisieren
wobei aber dann immer auch sozusagen das
eigene Fortkommen der eigenen Partei im
Vordergrund steht und man kann auch
konzentrieren dass der Rechtspopulismus
sowas wie die dunkle Seite der
repräsentativen Demokratie darstellt
also dazu gehört und es für die Parteien
die sich zum Pluralismus bekennen darum
gehen muss diese möglichst klein zu
halten und nicht zu nähren durch ähm
abercen zum Rechtspopulismus oder ein
zerschnittenes Außenbild wie man das bei
der Ampelkoalition ja in den letzten
Wochen sogar Monaten beobachten konnte
sprechen wir erstmal über die Avancen
sie sagen es braucht eine Brandmauer
gegen die AFD wird die weiter halten in
der Erzählung der AFD hat diese Mauer ja
mittlerweile ordentlich Risse
dieses Bild wird ja sehr hoch gehalten
und gleichzeitig hat auch heute zum
Beispiel Sachsens Ministerpräsident
Kretschmer für eine Zusammenarbeit zum
Beispiel mit dem neu gewählten Thüringer
Landrat Sesselmann geworden
ja wenn der Landrat AFD Mitglied ist
dann muss es da quasi in irgendeiner
Form auch eine Kooperation mit den
anderen Parteien geben das geht ja gar
nicht anders
ich würde trotzdem weiter dafür
plädieren an der Brandmauer zu arbeiten
die aufrecht zu erhalten weil mit Blick
auf Belgien muss Sanitär gibt sieht man
dass das eigentlich das einzige Mitte
ist um den Rechtspopulismus einzuheben
weil das kann man immer nur wieder ganz
deutlich betonen der Rechtspopulismus
Hand an die repräsentative Demokratie
legen möchte an die liberale Demokratie
wie wir sie kennen und da ist das auch
wenn es eine Kehrseite hat ein privates
Mittel in anderen Ländern in Nordeuropa
insbesondere sehen wir wo diese
Brandauer
eingerissen wurde eingestürzt ist dass
es dann sozusagen eben ein bisschen
Koalition Kooperation der
christdemokratischen konservativen
Partei mit dem Rechtspopulismus gab und
am Ende doch immer auch für die
konservative Mainstream Partei die
Gefahr da steht als Verlierer aus einer
Kooperation mit dem Rechtspopulismus
herauszugehen
ist das auch der Punkt den ein
cdu-parteichef sieht und deshalb solche
Aussagen trifft wir im ZDF
sommerinterview gesagt hat zur
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD auf
kommunaler Ebene
ich glaube da hat er zunächst einmal
beschrieben dass es diese Kooperationen
schon gibt und ich glaube das muss man
auch anerkennen das kann man in der
Politik nicht einfach totschweigen das
ist das schon gibt immer an
verschiedenen Stellen auch jetzt nicht
nur in mit Blick auf die CDU aber sein
sein seine Schlussfolgerung die hätte
dann tatsächlich anders ausfallen müssen
zu sagen es gibt es gab schon einzelne
Kooperationen aber es ist wichtig dass
wir auch dort die brandenauer aufrecht
erhalten und das hat er ja dann wenige
Stunden später nach dem ZDF Interview
auch noch gemacht oder dadurch hat er
mal wieder ambivalente Signale in die
eigene Partei und auch in Richtung AFD
ausgesendet was dann am Ende eine kleine
kommunikative Katastrophe war
und sie sagen ja gleichzeitig auch
Deutschland
sollte diesen rechts Populismus
aushalten wie meinen Sie das genau wie
man was man damit aushalten meinen sie
aussitzen durchhalten gegen Angebote
schaffen
ja also ich glaube das was wir am Anfang
gesagt haben das ist erstmal wichtig ist
einzugestehen dass Populismus
Rechtspopulismus sowas wie die dunkle
Seite der repräsentativen Demokratie
heutzutage darstellt also irgendwo dazu
gehört es ist eine Reaktion auf die
Krise der repräsentativen Demokratie
Demokratie ist heutzutage sehr sehr
kompliziert das ist ein mehr Ebenen
System und da kann ich nachvollziehen
dass ich da an manchen Stellen das
Gefühl der Entfremdung auch der mit
Blick auf die Politik der Abgehobenheit
darstellt aber man kann als
Politikwissenschaftler immer wieder da
rumwerben sagen Demokratie und Politik
ist nun mal kompliziert und man kann ein
ganz vielen Stellen Stellschrauben
drehen sich einbringen und ich glaube da
muss es auch eine Weiterentwicklung von
Demokratie geben dass Menschen sich
wieder stärker in ihrer Demokratie
beheimatet fühlen durch bürgerinnenräte
durch mehr direkte Demokratie auch durch
Parteien die gestärkt werden können
durch politische gesellschaftliche
Initiativen durch neue politische
Innovationen also da gibt's ganz ganz
viel Möglichkeiten die sozusagen dieser
Krise der repräsentativen Demokratie
etwas entgegenheiten können und am Ende
des Tages geht es dann eben für die ähm
für die Parteien die sich zum
Pluralismus bekennen darum ob sie durch
ihr Tun den Populismus nähren oder ob
sie ihn möglichst klein geringer hatten
und sehen Sie aktuell bei den
etablierten Parteien dass die eben an
diesen Stellschrauben diese gerade
beschrieben
jetzt könnten wir die einzelnen Parteien
uns separat anschauen über die
Ampelkoalition über die Zerstrittenheit
sprechen ob es der Sache immer gut tut
wenn sich eine einzelne Partei gegenüber
den anderen profiliert die Kanzlerpartei
sich dabei etwas zurücklehnt
habe und die Grüne Partei sicherlich
handwerkliche Fehler gemacht hat oder
auch unterschätzt hat die Stimmungslage
in der Bevölkerung dann können wir aber
auch oder müssen auch zu cdu/csu gehen
und es Fragen wird sie eigentlich ihrem
eigenen Anspruch gerecht als führende
Oppositionspartei so etwas wie die
Regierung im Wartestand zu sein das
heißt mit realistischen Konzepten mit
guten Ideen für das Land kommunikativ
durchzudringen also das ist vielleicht
im letzten in den letzten Wochen Monaten
eine etwas unglückliche
gesamtgemängelage gewesen die auch dazu
beigetragen hat dass dieser dass der
Rechtspopulismus auf dieser
demoskopischen Welle gerade reitet aber
an dieser Stelle auch noch mal ganz
deutlich Demoskopie sind nicht Wahlen
das heißt es bleibt dann auch zuwarten
ob die ob es der AFD gelingt im nächsten
Jahr bei den Landtagswahlen daran
anzuknüpfen was man jetzt demoskopisch
abbildet gehen wir noch mal kurz zum
Parteitag zurück wir hören mal ganz kurz
in die Rede von AFD
coiffaler rein
den Bayern und Hessen werden im Herbst
neue Landtage gewählt und nächstes Jahr
können wir in Sachsen Thüringen und
Brandenburg stärkste Kraftwerke wir
können Regierungsverantwortung
übernehmen und die Wende zum Guten
bewirken wir sind bereit für mehr das
ist unser Slogan dieses Parteitages
ja das sind diese Landtagswahlen die sie
auch gerade angesprochen haben und Timo
Pala ist sich relativ klar dass die AFD
damit regieren wird ist dieser
regierungsanspruch den er da dieser
Machtanspruch den erhebt gerechtfertigt
ich glaube das ist erstmal nicht
überrascht dass seine
rechtspopulistische Partei regieren
möchte weil es gibt die These das
argumentiert wird in der
Politikwissenschaft eigentlich geht es
doch auch nur darum an die Macht zu
kommen und alles andere auf dem Weg
dahin was ich bietet was man als
parteiinstrumentalisieren kann das
instrumentalisiert man nutzt man deshalb
sprechen wir in der Politikwissenschaft
auch von einer dünnen Ideologie des
Rechtspopulismus das heißt erst in der
Lage anders als Ebene linke Partei eine
grüne Partei oder eine
christdemokratische Partei die einen
Wertefundament hat sich flexibel bei
anderen Ideologien Versatzstücke zu
nehmen sie zu im eigenen Sinne zu
instrumentalisieren insofern ja es gibt
die Macht Ambitionen ganz klar und in
Ostdeutschland ist man da auch näher
dran als in Westdeutschland nur glaube
ich nicht dass es für eine
Alleinregierung reicht das heißt man
bräuchte einen Bündnispartner und das
ist im Grunde nur die CDU und die CDU
hat aber eine klare Beschlusslage dass
sie das nicht möchte und insofern
ist das auch glaube ich eher im Bereich
der politischen Kommunikation zu
verordnen an diesem Wochenende geht das
ja bei der AFD auch um die Europawahl
und wie sich die AFD auf EU-Ebene
positioniert und heute hat sie ihm
beschlossen der europäischen Partei Idee
beizutreten das ist ein Dachverband
rechter Parteien in Europa wie würden
Sie diesen diesen Schritt einschätzen
was bedeutet das
ja das ist erstmal müsste man sich
genauer anschauen aber erstmal eine
normale Erscheinung dass sich
rechtspopulistische Parteien europaweit
zusammenfinden da gibt es ja
unterschiedliche Formationen im
Europäischen Parlament um dann sozusagen
koordiniert an einem gemeinsamen Strang
zu ziehen und alle haben ja im Grunde
stehen alle rechtspopulistischen
Parteien in der Tradition des
eurospizismus das heißt sie haben den
Problemen mit einer stärker werdenden
Europäischen Union hat man ja auch im
Vorfeld jetzt das Leid Antrags bei der
AFD gesehen dass man da zuerst von einer
geordneten Auflösung der EU sprach und
dann doch wieder zurückgefordert ist
also es geht auch bei diesen Parteitag
nachdem die kandidieren aufgestellt
wurden um das Programm und wenn man das
kurz zusammenfasst geht es eigentlich
darum die radikal positioniert man sich
gegenüber der Europäischen Union und da
wird man wahrscheinlich doch etwas
Radikalität rausnehmen weil man erkennt
dass es dann in der eigenen Basis
wahrscheinlich doch gar nicht so gut
ankommen würde und es ist ja durchaus
Sinn macht in bestimmten Bereichen eng
definierten Bereichen zusammenarbeiten
wie zum Beispiel in der
Wirtschaftspolitik wir haben noch mal
eine andere Frage von Sebastian Wolter
auf Youtube wie gut sind die
Verbindungen der AFD zu Russland gibt es
da auch vielleicht eine finanzielle
Unterstützung der Partei
nicht dass ich wüsste dass da offiziell
etwas nachgewiesen wäre aber es gibt
Indizien dafür oder es gab Reisen
verschiedene afd-abgeordneter auch zum
Beispiel der AFD Landtagsfraktion in
Sachsen-Anhalt also Mitglieder der
Landtagsfraktion nach Russland wir haben
das ja hier auch am Anfang gesehen dass
es da doch eine starke Zugewandtheit
gegenüber Russland gibt dass man da auch
eine andere Position im Ukraine Konflikt
hat als die anderen Bundestagsparteien
also insofern gibt es da eine Nähe und
wir wissen wiederum auch von Russland
das sozusagen Russland danach strebt die
Kräfte in anderen europäischen Ländern
zu stärken finanziell aber auch durch
Social Media Agitation die sozusagen
daran mitwirken dass die repräsentativen
Demokratien in ihren Grundfesten nicht
erschüttert aber dass man daran
zumindest
ich hätte zum Schluss noch meine Frage
zu den Umfragen also die AFD erreicht
seit einiger Zeit in Umfragen
höchstwertwerte wenn man aber diese
Menschen nach konkreten Forderungen der
Partei fragt also zum Beispiel Austritt
aus der NATO oder Wiedereinführung der
D-Mark dann möchte das eine Mehrheit
nicht wie geht das zusammen
ja ich würde behaupten dass die
wenigsten sich jetzt mit den mit den
Forderungen der AFD im Detail vertraut
machen also hat auch immer sozusagen ist
auch immer eine unmutsbekundung
gegenüber der den repräsentativen System
gegenüber den anderen Parteien und
generell gilt für den Rechtspopulismus
dass er ganz viele Ambivalenzen
aufzuweisen hat das heißt man muss auch
ein Stück weit wenn man die AFD Analyse
macht damit leben das ist Ambivalenzen
gibt das heißt das ist kein
geschlossenes Weltbild ist sondern dass
da Sachen nebeneinander stehen an
programmatischen Forderungen die gar
nicht zueinander passen wo andere
Parteien
dazu zumindest vorsichtiger wäre
würde ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich
dafür dass Sie uns diese Ambivalenzen
erklärt haben und ihre Sicht der Dinge
geschildert haben ich wünsche Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend tschüss
Wochenende ihr hoffentlich auch macht's
gut bis bald tschüss